salut à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
profil d'un joueur à la draft NBA 2023
un joueur candidat il s'appelle Anthony
black et on va vous donner les clés pour
comprendre son jeu et sa possibilité en
une vingtaine de minutes
Anthony black né le 20 janvier 2004 dans
le Texas il jouait à Arkansas cette
saison chez les razerbax au poste plutôt
de meneur il mesure il est grand pour sa
position de mettre sans chaussures ce
sont les mesures du NBA combine donc
officiel 95 kg de mettre 0,2 d'envergure
donc quasiment une envergure équivalente
à sa taille pour en parler nous avons
Manu nous avons Julien salut les gars
Anthony black qui est vu très haut dans
le classement de valeurs d'ispn qu'il
voit 8e pareil chez diatlétique 10e chez
the Ringer un peu plus bas pour nous
chez envergure dans notre bigboard tel
qu'il est à ce jour il est 16e mais il
est quand même dans le dans le top 27
draft d'abord il sort d'où petite
biographie express avec toi Julien ce
Anthony black alors
parce que ça tombe sur ses yeux ça
m'énerve mais c'est un autre problème
qui vient de du thé que ça il est né à
duncanville
de High School il est senior à
dunkelville duncanville High School à la
fin c'est un enfant de la balle sa mère
jouer au soccer
football européen et son papa Terry
black c'est un basketteur qui est au
holophene de paylor donc c'est quand
même pas n'importe qui
donc voilà belle entourage bien entouré
et bien amené jusqu'à son début de
carrière qui est quand même pour
l'instant très prometteur il est il a
participé au fameux McDonald's
oui le McDonald's d'accord
mais il a été aussi au championnat des
c'est magnifique celui-là et j'ai revu
quelques matchs j'ai revu Manu j'en ai
revu un quand même pour me faire plaisir
c'est quand même une sacrée boucherie et
c'était pas mal les donc les États-Unis
qui gagnent haut la main le championnat
voilà
alors par rapport à son recrutement
recrute 5 étoiles plusieurs collèges
sont sur le coup et en fait il parle de
rejoindre à 10 digue
et de façon comment dire
au dernier moment il rejoint Arkansas
est-ce que c'est coéquipiers l'ont
poussé à venir on le verra
je parle de ces joueurs préférés parce
que ça peut être pas mal quand même
celui qui cite en premier c'est Gilbert
il a dit dans son enfance
c'est comme ça il devait bien aimer ses
maillots après un certain genre de
basket qui s'appelle Kobe Bryant voilà
et plus récemment alors séduit c'est je
vais le citer judged Josh gay pardon
parce que c'est un grand distributeur
pas très rapide ça c'est la réponse que
les interviews attendent
voilà et sinon quelques dingham parce
que il vient du Texas aussi que je pense
que ce soit un petit peu croisés voilà
pour le
photographie les préférences de Anthony
black donc effectivement des cheveux
assez incroyables
une tête de bébé il y a vraiment une
tête de bébé moi je l'ai vu encore
pendant le MP3
mais il faisait les interviews là sur le
côté il y a vraiment une il fait son âge
pour le coup il vient d'avoir 19 ans
autant il y en a qui sont plus mature
physiquement autant lui tu peux te dire
que il va il va peut-être maturer plus
tard qu'est-ce qu'il faisait cette année
à Arkansas Manu est-ce que tu peux nous
donner le contexte les responsabilités
qu'on lui donnait ce qu'on lui demande
de faire
c'est un joueur qui était titulaire
quasiment la pièce centrale de l'attaque
d'Arkansas premier porteur de balle
exclusif sur quasiment toute la saison
donc il a il a pu montrer toutes ses
qualités à la passe et vision donc ça
c'était super intéressant et
défensivement c'est un mec qui était
capable de défendre sur quasiment tout
le monde c'est souvent lui qui
s'occupait du meilleur leur adverse par
exemple donc voilà c'est quand c'était
quasiment le meilleur défenseur de son
équipe qui en avait pourtant des des
solides défenseurs sur son équipe ouais
ouais c'est une grosse équipe défensive
et
du coup autour de lui des joueurs très
jeunes et au niveau de tu dis leader
offensif et ce qu'on lui demandait de
créer sur pick and roll et ce qui crée
plus sur du 1 contre 1
c'était beaucoup bah après le NCIS il y
a pas beaucoup de pic and roll à
proprement parler tu vois
c'était pas le pique également longtemps
moi je l'entends actuellement à NBA tu
vois
mais mais il y en avait franchement
c'est un gars qui capable de créer pour
les autres multiples façons que ce soit
sur sur des poses d'écran sur sur un peu
plus tout seul sur sur l'élimination de
son vis-à-vis et du coup en fait je
pense qu'il
cette création celle-là aidé parce que
il est entouré des joueurs quand même
pas mal entre mes vieux beaucoup de
seniors tu vois qui était présent
peut-être l'une des équipes les plus
vieilles de sa conf c'est tous les
joueurs importants de l'équipe c'était
soit des juniors soit des seniors et
accepter les fraîches la cuvée de
fraîchement où ils étaient trois jours
quatre
vraiment très très jeune où ils avaient
un rôle
en dent de si selon les dispo de chacun
et le jeu donc je pense qu'il a un peu
pati par contre du manque de spacing
comme ou très très peu de vrais shooters
donc ça c'est la celle là un peu
fait mal parce que c'est vraiment un
joueur qui est qui voit qui voit tout
autour de lui et très très bien donc je
pense un peu plus de de spacing un peu
plus de vrais shooter ça encore l'auront
lieu encore un peu plus meilleur
effectivement un ratio
à 6 turn over qui est pas extraordinaire
pour un joueur qui a joué à la même ce
qui est de 1,3
Revenge il a d'autres
points forts statistiques on parle
notamment de son free for race pourtant
c'est pas censé être un joueur très
athlétique
mais il est à 58 de fouet alors en même
temps il tente pas énormément de choses
mais ça veut dire qu'il provoque quand
même beaucoup de lancer France 190
lancers
ça veut dire que ça veut dire 6 par
match quoi en gros un peu moins quand
même donc
Julien qu'est-ce qu'on achète qui
qu'est-ce qu'on achète chez Anthony
black pourquoi on le draft
pour sa vision de jeu pour sa vision de
jeu couplé à une défense effectivement
assez forte à la place il s'est un peu
près tout faire
il passe beaucoup à une main et à demain
tout main droite je l'ai pas vu trop
utiliser sa main gauche par contre mais
tous les types de passes rebonds
par dessus la tête
dépasse en courant arrêt il est
tellement en fait il est grand il est
plus grand que ses adversaires donc il
voit bien le jeu il en parle souvent
aussi de ça
il a une vision de jeu quoi qui est
assez forte et puis effectivement
défense fait plein de choses c'est un
défenseur rebondeur alors j'ai plus
compris
[Musique]
voilà après au niveau des styles il doit
être pas mal par contre j'ai plus la
stat mais au niveau des il a des mains
très très actifs il est toujours sur les
lignes de passe et ce qui est pas mal
c'est quand il aura t il s'énerve quoi
donc il sent qu'il peut l'avoir et qui
la passe une heure c'est un défenseur
direct
Manu est-ce que tu t’attes à d'autres
choses à ajouter est-ce que pour toi on
peut le drafter pour autre chose que
pour sa vision de jeu parce qu'une
vision de jeu il faut qu'elle soit
accompagnée d'autres choses qu'est-ce
qu'il a dans son bagage qui peut
intéresser une équipe visiblement dans
le top 10 même certains hipsters qui
passent dans le top 5 alors il faut il
faut expliquer aux gens
pour moi c'est pas un ski Les en
particulier mais c'est son c'est plus un
rôle c'est celui de connecteur je pense
que c'est le ça va être un gap parfait
qui va qui va pouvoir aider comme ça
tout toutes les équipes à trouver
l'extrapasse la passe d'avant la passe
enfin là ok assiste les gens vont plus
comprendre comme ça et du coup c'est ce
vraiment ce connecteur facilitateur
d'attaque qui où il va pouvoir
fluidifier il va pouvoir voilà moi pour
moi c'est ça qui qui me moi en tout cas
me fait le l'aimer ou en plus de
l'attaque enfin la vision et la défense
ok donc connecteur ça veut dire qu'il a
un bon dribble on est d'accord
[Musique]
pour moi un connecteur c'est plus
quelqu'un qui a une enfin en avance sur
sur son temps entre guillemets en avance
sur la tête
le cerveau voit il faut quand même avoir
des capacités techniques c'est ce que je
veux dire
ça veut pas dire qu'il bat son
adversaire en dribble ça veut dire qu'il
est capable de driver quoi ouais ouais
capable de driver capable c'est pas un
mauvais athlète max vertical libre je
suis en train de regarder 39 inches donc
ça fait combien ça remet
ça fait 80 90 cm c'est pas mal c'est pas
mal en terme de
détente max
et même sur le sur le sprint trois
cartes terrain s'il était pas dans les
plus rapides mais pas dans les plus
ridicules non plus du NBA combine
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui te doit
travailler Julien c'est quoi vraiment le
truc qui peut débloquer en fait un
niveau supérieur chez lui
c'est assez évident je pense c'est son
shoot quoi
son 4ème soute
d'ailleurs il entend un peu il a pas
confiance
voilà il y a 93 shoot il a 93 soutes il
faut dire qu'il a il a entendu
monstrueux quand même
il a pris 93 il y a 30%
et puis quand on le voit shooter c'est
quand même pas très Jojo c'est très lent
alors il y a des fois c'est assez fluide
et puis la plupart du temps en gros il
est pas il est pas calé son foot quoi
donc il y a un gros gros travail à faire
sur le shoot parce que voilà s'il veut
avoir ce rôle de s'il va voir le ballon
en main en NBA il va falloir aussi qu'il
trouve un moyen de scorer de façon
efficace quoi pour maintenir la pression
sur sur lui et pour pouvoir libérer ses
coéquipiers
après mon drive juste Manu moi j'ai
trouvé qu'il était pas comment dire
j'ai pas été convaincu s'il y a pas un
écran en fait tu vois ce qui veut dire
si il utilise pas un écran j'ai
l'impression qu'il arrive à battre peu
de mon ni avec sa vitesse ni avec sa
puissance il a un bas du corps qui est
assez costaud quand même il a des gens
qui sont qui sont costauds le discord
est un peu plus frile mais ça lui permet
pas de passer en puissance sur du un
contrat et alors moi j'ai noté deux
trois actions où il arrive même pas à
passer un
pivot quoi peut-être que j'exagère
peut-être que j'exagère mais j'ai
l'impression que c'est pas voilà au
niveau du drive il a besoin d'un écran
de tu le vois pas porteur de ballon
principal d'une équipe quoi
mais je le vois plus dans le rôle que
donne Manu connecteur qui est connecté
parce que j'aime bien ce terme mais ça
veut dire quoi qui est connecteur
aujourd'hui en NBA
[Rires]
allez terminer
il joue quand même pas mal de possession
avec le ballon ouais ouais c'est ce type
de joueur là
quand même et tu vois ils ont
un peu les mêmes défauts point fort
défaut aussi je trouve c'est un sorti
une Florida State ce que dit pas
forcément beaucoup beaucoup de choses
non plus c'est stade quasiment pareil
ouais je pense que
il est un peu plus grand c'est un mec
qui même bien plus grand
ou je me trompe ou en tout cas plus
costaud
s
un pied de plus ouais 3 cm de plus pas
énorme il est grand Anthony black
on croit que c'est une illusion
d'optique à cause de ses cheveux mais
quand même vachement grand il est plus
grand que son coéquipier Jordan Wals qui
jouait trois quatre quoi
par exemple
U18 américain l'année dernière il jouait
4 Anthony black ouais donc tu penses que
son avenir finalement est pas
nécessairement à la même comme on
l'entend aujourd'hui traditionnellement
pour moi s'il veut maximiser son son
talent et avoir 10 minutes d'avoir un
vrai rôle en NBA irriture c'est pour moi
je le mets seconde seconde initiateur
connecteur comme ça tu as c'est un mec
qui pour moi il a besoin s'il a pas la
balle en main il sert à rien ok
parce qu'ici la pâte tire
les gens vont laisser vas-y il va être
plus ou moins fixé il sera pas défendu
quoi malgré ce manque de tir il est
arrivé à se créer de l'attaque je disais
au taux de fruits trop après il y avait
beaucoup de transitions
sur les rebonds offensifs ou comme il se
bat tout le temps bah en fait il avait
pas mal de sur les seconds chances comme
ça il avait pas mal de fautes aussi
et tu vois là il y a un mec qui vient en
tête c'est un peu un hibou gala
même si je pense qu'il est plus évolué
offensivement qui goudala en termes de
polyvalence voilà de vision de faire
plus de choses
c'est vrai que le goût de la succès
mais je comprends l'idée
après faut vraiment que qui sanctionne
en fait quand il ouvert quel qu'il soit
qu'il soit à 35 % minimum parce que là
c'est un 30% la plupart des tirs sont
quand même bien ouverts
après il y a le contexte Archange qui
joue beaucoup là-dedans mais bon sur sa
réussite à 3 pouces
en fait dès qu'il est en mouvement il
est fort en fait dès qu'il est en
mouvement qu'il est lancé et du coup il
a pas eu tant de ça de cut parce que en
fait la pâte feuilleting avec plus de
spacing il peut courir il peut et c'est
là où il est fort il va attraper le
ballon il va attaquer le panier et
provoquer des fautes avec un vrai meneur
et un ailier qui peut porter aussi la
balle il sera beaucoup plus en mouvement
il y aura beaucoup plus de de choses
pour lui aussi peut-être de fluidité va
peut-être
revoir dans un autre rôle en fait dans
un autre contexte ou c'est là où il
était vraiment intéressant du coup avec
timio et c'est
ou justement il y avait il y avait des
meneurs ils portaient pas la balle
jamais il faisait beaucoup de cut
beaucoup d'activités au rebond des deux
côtés et c'est comme ça que provenait
c'est il faut lui mettre du spaceing
autour du coup Manu l'année prochaine
dès l'année prochaine c'est ça la clé
quand même
bah si on en fait un porteur ouais je
pense
ça pourra l'aider de par sa vision à
mieux faire son équipe et du coup si
spacing avec shooter bah lui il pourra
aussi aller un peu plus au cercle et
psychologiquement Julien qu'est-ce que
ça donne chez Anthony black
qui est un joueur comme je disais qu'il
fait très jeune mais puisque ça donne
dans ses réponses dans ces dans ce que
tu as pu dire ou entendre de lui dans ce
qu'on peut voir
ces gestuelles
hors basket alors en basket il a l'air
assez serein en fait dans les interviews
il est assez serein il est pas aussi pro
que son coéquipier Nick Smith mais il
est il est bien il serait répondu en
question je trouve
dans les interviews il a été sur les
épaules quoi après les échos qui
tournent autour de lui c'est que c'est
un gars qui est vraiment très très
gentil très gentil avec ses coéquipiers
il est adoré de ses coéquipiers partout
il est passé
il fait très attention tous les gens qui
sont autour de lui donc moi j'ai vu
aucun Red Flag sur le terrain c'est un
gamin qui a du caractère parfois il y a
des
vif quoi mais voilà c'est le genre de
gars qui va qui va ramasser les mêmes
les adversaires quand ils sont à terre
voilà ça a l'air d'être un gars
sympathique il y a une tête de gentil
quand même
Manu qui est-ce que tu crois est-ce que
tu crois qu'il va atteindre la valeur
d'un top 10 puisque visiblement on se
dirige vers ça si on croit les échos
qu'on a à ce 14 juin côté di espienne
dire athlétique enfin les gens qui sont
un peu mieux informés que nous même si
on est bien informés qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que tu crois qu'il va
atteindre cette valeur là
pour moi il lui faut absolument un bon
contexte et il est annoncé quasiment
depuis le début dans les dans les moques
à Washington et s'il tombe à Washington
de ce que j'ai vu
enfin moi je crois beaucoup potentiel
j'ai un peu plus peur je pense qu'il
peut exister c'est important
vu qu'il en a pas
je pense qu'il va s'améliorer parce que
le l'ESTA fait une Bièvre ont travaillé
là-dessus mais
je poste même si à terme il fait des
saisons à 30 33 % à 3 points je pense
qu'il arrivera quand même à exister de
par sa défense et de sa polyvalence
d'attaque et ce rôle de connecteur de
que j'ai en tête j'y crois
un créateur défenseur son shoot j'ai
l'impression qu'on en a parlé souvent et
que ça marche pas tout le temps mais il
a ouais il faut parler potentiel il a
plein de basket dans les mains il est
enthousiaste il se bat en défense
et un foot c'est peut-être pas le plus
compliqué à travailler ça c'est vrai et
si ce compare avec Josh geedis c'est pas
pour rien Josh Gigi non plus il avait
pas trop de shoot alors c'était un
meilleur playmaker
[Musique]
dans dans la crème de la crème
c'était tout c'était notre résumé sur le
jeu de Anthony black joueur d'arc-en-sas
pour trouver tous les autres portraits
de cette draft demi NBA 2023 sur notre
YouTube et sur vos applis d'écoute notre
site c'est envergure.co pour tout ce qui
est écrit ciao tout le monde